in the era of ROI more sexual assault
allegations a resignation by Democratic
senator Al Franken
and the entire thing surrounding the new
frequent allegations of sexual assault
there is a sort of glaring hypocrisy
which is that the President of the
United States Donald Trump has suffered
absolutely no consequences related to
his more than a dozen actually don't
even know what the number is at this
point more than a dozen sexual assault
allegations the Access Hollywood tapes
called into question in terms of their
authenticity by Donald Trump over the
last few weeks no investigation nothing
that might change a number of the women
who have publicly accused Donald Trump
of sexual assault are getting together
to demand a congressional investigation
be started into Donald Trump's behavior
remember that the official position of
the White House is that the women all of
Donald Trump's accusers women who don't
know each other women whose accusations
range in time periods over many many
years or even decades the White House's
position on all of those allegations is
that the women are simply lying
will this coalescing of some of these
accusers lead to anything
probably not I wish I could be more
optimistic but more than likely this is
something that will lead to press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
expressing that she's offended and
indignation at the mere suggestion that
Donald Trump would ever sexually harass
anyone despite the fact that his own
ex-wife accused him of rape it might
lead to a Trump Twitter rant about the
failings of the fake news media and
criticizing the women in question but
more than likely it's not going to lead
to a congressional investigation if
anything it will lead to more focus from
Republicans on Bill Clinton or Hillary
Clinton because why not right that's
always a popular refrain from the right
and remember I keep saying because it's
it's one of these one of the most
flaccid and pointless defenses that I've
ever heard of Donald Trump's actions or
alleged action
is that Trump was a Democrat at the time
that these alleged incidents took place
which is both not true completely anyway
and it's patently absurd as well and
what would actually I mentioned Ivana
Trump of one of Donald Trump's ex-wives
it would be useful and very powerful
actually if Donald Trump's ex-wife Ivana
would join in and demanding this invest
in investigation her story of being
raped by Donald Trump when they were
married is absolutely horrifying but
that's gonna be a non-starter for some
people on the right who believe that
there is no such thing as marital rape I
get emails from those people actually
we'll see if anything comes of it